okay all up here up unicorn oh oh I  should get to rearrange doesn't matter  this is gonna be a cinch  oh distracted worried  [Music]  how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems  like Elsa there's this voice voice what  does that mean  the kingdom is not safe find who is  calling to you they may have answers  across the enchanted lands and into the  unknown if we do this together okay  the spirits will challenge you every  step of the way  [Music]  that's normal who are you I'm Ola oh  sorry yeah I just find clothes  restricting  No  should I know what that means  [Music]  scream  magic disappearing without you see bein  lose herself to it  more than anyone or anything  if anyone can save arendelle it's you  you guys cope with the ever increasing  complexity of thought that comes with  maturity oh no no don't you that you  don't know what I stepped in  you